BACK ABOVE THE 25,000 MARK.
S&P 500 UP 24.
NASDAQ FINISHED I HAD 51.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS TOUTING HIS
OWN INFLUENCE IN HIGH REPUBLICAN
TURNOUT IN PRIMARY ELECTIONS
HELD YESTERDAY IN EIGHT STATES.
MUCH OF THE FOCUS WAS ON
CALIFORNIA WHERE THE STATE'S
UNUSUAL JUNGLE FORMAT COULD HAVE
LOCKED OUT ONE PARTY COMPLETELY
OUT OF THE NOVEMBER RACES.
COURSE BY THE PETER DOOCY HAS AN
UPDATE.
>> CALIFORNIA'S GUBERNATORIAL
PRIMARY DIDN'T HAVE A BLUE WAVE.
INSTEAD, A REPUBLICAN RIPTIDE.
>> MAKE CALIFORNIA THE
GOLDEN STATE ONCE AGAIN.
>> WITH THAT FAMILIAR SOUNDING
SLOGAN AFTER A STRONG FINISH TO
PUT THEM ON THE BALLOT,
REPUBLICAN JOHN COX IS
CHANNELING PRESIDENT TRUMP WHILE
DEMOCRAT GAVIN NEWSOM IS
TWEETING TO HIM, URGING THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF TO GO FURTHER
THAN JUST CONGRATULATING THE
CANDIDATE HE HELPED WITH AN
ENDORSEMENT WITH THIS.
"PLEASE COME CAMPAIGN FOR HIM AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE."
>> VOTERS WILL HAVE A REAL
CHOICE THIS NOVEMBER BETWEEN THE
GOVERNMENT WAS GOING TO STAND UP
TO DONALD TRUMP AND A FOOT
SOLDIER AND HIS WAR ON
CALIFORNIA.
>> JOHN COX IS CORRECTING
NEWSOM.
>> IT WASN'T DONALD TRUMP THAT
PASSED THE SANCTUARY STATE.
GAVIN, YOU DID THAT.
>> CALIFORNIA'S AIRWAVES HAVE
BEEN BLANKETED WITH COMMERCIALS.
TURNOUT WAS A SOFT 21.9%, 3%
LOWER THAN THE 2014
GUBERNATORIAL PRIMARY.
SOME VOTERS RUN INTO TROUBLE
BECAUSE A PRINTING PROBLEM IN
L.A. COUNTY LEFT 118,000
RESIDENTS OFF THE ROLES AND 1500
PRECINCTS.
>> IT WAS AS MANY AS A FEW
HUNDRED.
>> WASN'T JUST A LONG NIGHT FOR
THE L.A. REGISTRAR.
IT TOOK HOURS TO LEARN
DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN WHO
FAILED TO WIN THE STATE PARTIES
ENDORSEMENT WOULD BE CHALLENGED
BY THE MORE PROGRESSIVE STATE
SENATOR KEVIN DE LEON.
IT ALSO TOOK A WHILE UNTIL
RESULTS IN ORANGE COUNTIES
EXPENSIVE PRIMARIES BEGAN TO
TRICKLE IN AND WHEN THEY DID,
DEMOCRATS WERE RELIEVED TO HAVE
SEEN CANDIDATES CLAW THEIR WAY
ONTO BALLOTS EVERYWHERE,
INCLUDING DISTRICTS THEY RISKED
COMING IN THIRD PLACE.
TOO LOW FOR THE NOVEMBER BALLOT.
DEMOCRATIC COMMITTEE SAYS ITS
INVESTMENTS IN CALIFORNIA WILL
CONTINUE TO PAY DEVIN'S IN
NOVEMBER AND BEYOND.
TALK LIKE THAT DOESN'T IMPRESS
ONE INCUMBENT.
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN DANA
ROHRABACHER.
>> HOW MANY TIMES DO WE HAVE TO
HEAR THERE'S A BLUE WAVE?
>> REPUBLICANS ARE DEFENDING TEN
HOUSE SEATS HERE.
FOUND LATE LAST NIGHT THE
AVENUE